I got gifts yeah one for you one for me
okay and one for you jo-jo an extra big
bow okay so girl coffee and tea on my
favorite things I got you so these are
on and I need to be calm it's common
right and then look when you sip in that
it reminds you to be still oh my god
that's one of my songs I wrote a song
called be still like a long time one of
my records and literally that's like my
favorite well it's meant thing you
should tell myself cuz I don't all right
so you I heard that you like a lot of
sweet things oh yeah Oh cookie cutters
so cute a little recipe card so you can
have someone make them for you on tour
oh yes you can make them to decorate
that I'm glad I didn't get that one cuz
I can't cook it all Nashville is that
not right open the restaurant that I
don't know how to cook I trust it
wouldn't be open very long everyone get
them into the Christmas spirit because
they can cook with you know the other
girl
- grill cook in the kitchen rarely but
he loves grilling it's really good so
you're like the queen of Christmas well
yeah the hallmark queen of Christmas so
I must bring Christmas cheer wherever I
get my sister and mother so jealous
right now I can't even tell you like
they've seen everything you yeah what
we've all loved you said that's why on
your card I was like I feel like I've
never seen TV without you on it like
like since I was a child you don't want
a long time it's awesome thank you well
we're not that old
I'm Jenn around your age so what did you
forgot though so all of these items are
from my home and decor line Oh Dayspring
and I have given all of these to the
audience
[Applause]
just film the it's the final episode for
fuller house right was that tough it was
I cried for like you know a couple weeks
I cry all the time and it's fine Jason
oh yeah you can see me I was uh I was
instagramming part of the the the final
day and it was very emotional because
these I've been working with these
people for 30 years and you feel like
when you if you're on a hit show you
struck lightning struck yeah once to
have it strike twice yeah is almost
unimaginable but then to have lightning
strike twice with your best friends is
like its luckiest life ever yes
experience on shows and I've talked a
lot of actors now I mean the show and
not everybody has that experience that's
a blessing Oh a huge blessing yeah I
think so y'all had fun at the wrap party
though what's happening what's happening
there I saw I saw well one I saw photo
and I saw some footage we're gonna get
to well it was a great wrap party and
then they pull this up on stage for
karaoke and we were singing some new
kids on the block because who doesn't
I'm I not why not and and then they
surprised us and we sing the fuller
house theme song cuz everyone knows it
and that was really fun I'm totally sing
along I know the whole thing I don't
even know all the way kind of do you had
an unexpected audience I hear with
karaoke okay so the embarrassing part is
that karaoke Candice doesn't come out
very often it's like once in a while
Carrie cuz fun I know but I don't do
that publicly very often okay
rapping sir mix-a-lot
baby got back yeah yes so wait what was
the unexpected audience the part was
that I got a message the next morning
from Jodie Sweetin
she texted me a video message and she
was like hey Candace I'm outside and I
bet you didn't know but your video right
now is being broadcast to all of
Hollywood and Highland now for those of
you that don't know pins or at that or
when I was babbling at Lucky Strike
that's all in there and Hollywood and
Highland is like Times Square yes so my
karaoke version Oh like for everyone to
see your version of twerk it's just a
little a little so do you like karaoke I
love karaoke because people think that
singers are like over it but I love I
love karaoke but the weird it's weird if
you're a singer and you go in and you
sing your own song you know what I mean
you look like an idiot but do people
ever go like hey that guy's pretty good
he sounds just like him but like they
don't they don't get it that happened to
me once I was karaoke with Reba and then
she got up on stage we sang together
obviously they recognized her and but
they kept when she looks like Kelly
Clarkson and then Reba got on stage and
it was really awesome we were we had had
some drinks Kunis I love that you give
back during the holidays this is amazing
thing so tell us how you do that well
I've been working this is my second year
working with the Salvation Army and so
many of us we see those red kettles out
in front of the stores we hear the bells
ringing but a lot of people don't
realize where the money goes yeah so
anytime you donate to the Red Kettle it
stays right in your community and the
Salvation Army provides not only basic
needs like shelter and a warm meal and
Christmas presents for kids on Christmas
morning but they have things all over
the country they serve over 23 million
people a year through rehabilitation
program
and job training centers daycare they
really help people get back on their
feet
and just push through the circumstances
that they're in to be able to just get
up and get out and their help in their
lives they're healthy so just want to
remind everyone is it's the giving
season to remember to donate there's no
amount that's too small to donate to the
Red Kettle no more go to the website you
can even set up a reoccurring monthly
gift if you want my mother does that
she's so good
so she saves all the animals all the
family she's always saving people I'm
like you're such a good human thing to
do also to donate in someone's name for
that person who has everything for me a
donation that's a gift yes
all right can't I see you brought a few
friends today with you tell me about him
I did I brought the Salvation Army choir
and they are here to sing joy to the
world let's take it away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
repeat the sounding joy repeat the
sounding joy here's the world with truth
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this